there was no time to really get to those
other realms that's a whole other thing
so that's one realm i would love to go
visit and see what's going on over there
wow and all those fun characters that
you know and love that are over there
hello hello hello hold on oh my gosh is
this finally working get it on
oh yes it's working yes
well thank you for taking the time to
speak with us today uh this
movie was exceptionally entertaining
from beginning to end from beginning to
end um i'm also a fellow greg
and but i know this greg wants to be
more like you
i have to be this greg down the road oh
you are a great greg
big fan of your guy's channel thanks for
having me oh thank you so much
appreciate it
okay so i wanted to start off with a bit
of an odd question here and i and i
don't mean this
in any way that is mocking at all i mean
yeah
later on was there ever a moment
when you were writing this where you
were like
man this is so badass that you ever have
that like oh i'm gonna put in the line
kano wins and people are gonna love this
because it was stuff like that when we
were watching it up
that's pretty badass that that works
really well it was
it was often and uh i was i was
definitely probably by myself screaming
at my computer and enjoy way too much no
you never
know what's going to make it you know
that's the thing like you never know
what's going to make it to the movie you
put a lot of i put
so much fan service and so much love
into it but i just
had to hope that it made it through that
it made it through to the film and
what i found was working with this crew
and his team is that they loved it just
as much as i did you know warner
brothers new line was such an amazing
partner they basically let us just go
make a giant family
and we i kept expecting people to say
like don't like
pull back or don't do it or you can't do
that fatality you can't do anything
they're just like guys we know you know
this we know you love this uh stay
within the budget
and go go make a fun movie and we got to
do that it's it's nuts i still can't
believe we got to make this movie i it's
wild so
that's great i i mean you brought the
fatalities and and i was
wondering like a what is it like to
write
a fatality into it like how do you
describe that
and b was there fatalities that you were
right that you wrote originally that
they were just like no there's no way we
can pull this off there's no way we can
put this in this
in this first film there's no way we can
get the r rating with this
yeah that's a good question yeah and so
one of the cool things about being the
writer on monocom is you got to i got to
pick the fatalities so i got to choose
what they were where they happened and
the first thing as a writer the first
thing i do is make sure that they have a
place in the story
you know that they're not just showy
they're not just there to be there that
they actually make sense when they're
happening people are happening too that
has stakes that it matters right
yeah yeah okay so once that
screenwritery stuff is done uh then you
get to have fun then
yeah what is actually going down and so
for me as a huge fan like what i wanted
to do is i wanted to throw some love to
the og stuff like i wanted to go back to
the first couple games you know because
that's you know that's what i grew up on
i was i was in the arcade playing the
first couple games and so
uh there's just some iconic ones there's
some there's some that any
old school and i'm talking about the old
school fans like the ones that went to
the arcade
when you ask them about fatalities they
usually talk about those two games they
talk about like
toasty and they talk about the heart rip
and the spine rip and all that
stuff that they love from the from the
first game so i wanted some of that that
that stuff in there and then selfishly
i wanted to pick my favorite fatality
and so that's also in there
and that's uh that's a kung lao uh
moment that's what i was
that's a great example of like one thing
that i put in there that i was just like
ah please don't take this out like it
was like it's it's just like the most
it's my personal opinion the baddest
like most badass fatality in the whole
series
and so i was just like don't take it out
don't take it out and nobody did and
they when they filmed it like to their
credit like the crew is
i mean simon is an amazing director and
the crew that made this movie
they were so hell-bent on making those
fatalities look good and
the way to make them look good was to
not rely on cgi
and they were like and they would they
just went old school and they built [ __ ]
like
tom savini did like they built like old
school blood rigs and
fake heads and fake torsos like
there was you walk around settings like
you're in like a [ __ ] 70s horror
movie it was the coolest thing in the
world
yeah and i was like thank you guys
thanks for not just making it you know
all blue screen and cgi
like they look really
absolutely that was something that we
commented on after watching it was of
course there's times
you got to use cgi but when you you when
you have the opportunity to use
practical uh it it definitely shines
and we knew that so it's a balance right
like you can't you can't practical
superpowers right so when these guys
and we wanted them to do their moves we
wanted them to throw fireballs and to
throw you know ice balls and stuff so we
knew that there was going to be
a lot a good amount of cgi and so one
place we were always talking about like
how do we pull back and make sure that
that
there's also practical too and that felt
like a natural place to do it and the
fight scenes too like a lot of those
fight scenes are
really those guys slugging away on each
other uh lewis and
joe and and hiroyuki and these i mean
ludi they're all trained
they all know what the hell are you
doing and that was a big mission for us
in this movie it's like
the easy way would have been to go get
movie stars that had no idea what they
were doing to
you know i didn't know how to fight and
nobody wanted to do that part of our
mission statement was like if we're
going to be authentic let's go get
people that know what the hell they're
doing that can throw at the spinning
kick those kung lao kicks
he's really doing that like that he can
kick to like the ceiling it's the
weirdest it's the craziest thing i've
ever seen in my life oh it must have
been so cool to be on set
but it must have been so cool amazing
they're so talented i'm like the writer
with the back problems in the corner
like running away and i'm like
you guys are doing cool look at these
muscle beautiful people
spinning around it was like i'll be in
the yeah i'll be in my car
don't worry once you unlock your arcana
you'll have a super back
yeah mario kart is just yeah
just getting up in the morning and not
feeling any back pain
hey between between the three of us i
think that is a desirable
power right here right now
did you have a character that you
enjoyed most writing yeah it was you
know they're all they're all blast and
they all have their different voices and
part of it was you know i wanted to make
sure i was authentic too their voices
from the games like that's why
you know kung lao is written to be fun
and cocky because that's who he was
that's that's who he is and liu kang is
much more meditative and contemplative
because that's who he is
so i wanted to stay true to that um i
didn't want to go away from it and then
the one character that i
loved writing was probably kano i have
to i have to ask really quick
because that was something we were so
surprised by how funny kano was oh yeah
yeah was was that all you or did you let
him improvise
there's like a jim jeffries vibe about
this guy in the movie josh lawson is a
great talent he's huge in australia he's
done a lot of tv shows down there
he's been in like i think he was an
actor man too he played a kench allenby
uh the australian guy in anchorage here
just chopping full of boys but he's dead
he's
gonna i think among many actors i think
he's gonna really pop off this
yes absolutely and um again was a
character that
what i loved what i love when you do a
little ensemble like any kind of
ensemble group is that there's two ways
to do it right you could do it with just
all heroes and this is by the way this
is part of the reason why keno was there
more or less from act one you can do
with all the heroes right where they all
have their one pov and it's all like we
gotta go save the world and let's go do
it and here we go and what i love to do
is just throw in
a rogue [ __ ] it's like it's like
dropping a uh
like a ferret into a chicken pen you
know it's just like it makes everything
more difficult
it adds more drama it adds more conflict
adds more humor and so
i love the idea of throwing kano on
their side because he's such a prick and
he just constantly slows them down
and screws up everything that was part
of the reason why kano was there uh just
from a story perspective and then
writing him yeah a lot of that scripted
and josh is a great improver so i would
write some of those lines like uh one of
my favorite little moments
that i'll say is like when kano and
sonia are in the desert and he kind of
shoves her and
he goes you want to dance and then she
turns around she goes
it's your blood right and then and this
other great stuff you know
again a lot of that scripted and uh and
then josh is just an amazing improver he
comes in and he just takes it and comes
up with some wonderful
wonderful stuff and that's that's why
you get those kind of actors
that can do that because they really
bring a lot without going into too many
spoilers but
i think you might agree with me here one
of our favorite scenes that is not like
an
action scene yeah is when kung lao
and lou king are provoking kano at the
dinner table
like that to me wasn't like the moves
like a play
in that scene yeah it was it was one of
those scenes where
i think we just really tried even when
we weren't because we knew we were we
were a fight movie we knew that
the fight scenes were going to be cool
and that people are going to look
forward to them but we also want to make
sure that
when it wasn't fight scenes that they
were having fun that there was fun [ __ ]
going on and so you achieved that
yeah and that's a good example of a
scene where it's like
maybe in other writers hands it's people
eating dinner and they're talking about
[ __ ]
and you know it doesn't it doesn't go
there but we treated that scene like an
action scene we built it
it has a pace to it i love that scene
for kano as much as i love it for kung
lao
and yeah and luke because kung lao is so
great in that scene him just provoking
him
is is it's so much fun and as an
audience member you by this point in the
movie
you know no spoilers where it happens
but by this point you've come to really
not like you know
like you've come to you want someone to
really
stick it to them and so it's audience
fulfillment too it's like you get kung
lao and ludi they just like they just go
at them and
and it's a blast yeah it's a fun scene i
gotta ask is there
is there an extended version of this
movie because it's very evident you know
these characters is there ever you know
these personalities
and each one of them i was obviously
there's room for a sequel
i think we all were all gonna want one
like the scorpion sub-zero plot line
was probably my even though it's not the
most
i can't go to suppose yeah i thought the
most focal necessarily it's more like
cole young the main ensembles team
i was so drawn to that i'm like i would
love to see it's just a scorpion movie
of
the time in between from the prologue to
where he is now
or any one of these many characters is
there like an ex
what draft was the script because i
imagine there's probably a much longer
version too
yeah there was i mean you know when i
again when i came in so i came in five
years earlier
i worked on the movie the last five
years so okay i inherited
a script uh when i came on and there was
some structural stuff that that ends up
that we we kept
um but ultimately i got to rewrite it i
got to make it my own which i'm which
i'm happy and thankful for the
opportunity
that process is a long process and you
know it's many drafts it's many
different
ideas that don't go anywhere that we
pull back on you know one of the hard
things
being a fan of mortal kombat writing it
is that i wanted to
i often wanted to put more mythology and
stuff in here
that it could fit yeah so it was funny i
think in the production of this
and the development of this i was the
more like the mortal kombat guy that
anybody had a question i'd be like hey
does this work and i'd be like yeah
sure let's do it and then simon is a
great balance to me of the director
because
there'd be scenes that i'd written like
um like for example there's like a scene
and this doesn't know spoilers but
there's a scene with like shangsung and
molina you see in the trailer where
they're talking
i think originally i'd written that as
like a three-page scene where it's like
dense into molina's backstory and it
talks about katana and it talks about
adenia and all this stuff
and then simon you know the production
team gets involved in like craig there's
way too much
small person is gonna watch this and be
like what
that's it so you know you have to keep
that in mind it's that you're writing
you know
it's a movie's very different from a
game right like if i was writing mortal
kombat 12
it would just be all fans and that's
what they do they just put a ton of fan
service in there
but in the movie i've got people that
don't even know what mortal kombat is
that are coming to this movie and they
have to actually end it they have to
know what this world means and get
involved in it so
it's really about finding that balance
about pulling back uh sometimes
that stuff has been filmed will it yeah
it's probably out there maybe on the
deep maybe on the blu-ray or something
they'll put some of those scenes in
there you'll see a lot of me geeking out
in those
release the greg russo cut let's do this
there's a five-hour mortal kombat
version right there but no i i think i
think you're absolutely right because
a lot of people will mainly associate
the fight scenes and stuff but i think
that there's such a huge mythology to
mortal kombat that you there's a lot
i imagine you'd have to be in a position
of i gotta dial some of this back
yeah because only fans will get it you
know so much time too you know it's like
you own so much time and there's so much
that i have to get out
i don't want to i want to just
exposition bomb you you know i'm trying
to yeah
here's everything you need to know uh
but with the amount of characters that i
have to introduce and the amount of
mythology that i have to introduce um
there's yeah there's just so much time
you know i know they got like time for
like one more minute or so but john
please
take it away with the last question i
mean with all that in mind do you have a
laundry list of things you would like to
get to in a potential scenario
like do you have dream characters dreams
scenarios dream settings
yes i do man i know okay i can
um yeah so one thing you know i kind of
kept it to myself
when i wrote the script but any writer
is always leaving himself
uh avenues like you don't want to paint
yourself in a corner with one movie so i
always
like in my in the back of my mind i set
it up as a trilogy
and um nice and so even though i didn't
talk to people about this like we were
all focused on movie one
uh as the writer it's still i feel like
it's still part of my response but
because i'm just a huge nut and fan uh
that i just kind of i figured out where
i was going and so
part of that helped me with the very
difficult decision of who to include
and who not to include there are
definitely characters that i love that i
would have loved to have put in movie
one but it just felt like if i did that
it would have been a disservice to those
characters and it didn't feel like the
right time to bring them in
so that being said i am a huge fan of
the danis
denis storyline i'm a huge fan of kakana
and cindel and all those characters
and that's a world that you know movie
one is very it was very focused on
outworld and earth realm
and it felt like there was no time to
really get to those other realms that's
a whole other thing
so that's one realm i would love to go
visit and see what's going on over there
wow and all those fun characters that
you know and love that are that are over
there like jade and rain and
and you know them all so yeah i mean
we saw shout com uh statues and stuff
too so that's
all the dlc potential yeah think of all
the other characters like
politics little combat multiverse if i
was just like i just i just want to put
a robocop in terminal
yeah we got rambo in here we got
predator now
yeah oh um mr greg russo i really
appreciate the time that you took with
us today
kay is in good hands and you are mr greg
as well i appreciate that
and you're doing uh petting death note
too yeah
well yeah so that's another one that uh
that i that i've been on for about three
three and a half years and
another project that i've kind of kind
of rebooting
in a way so good no pressure
i'm i'm a big fan of the manga and so i
went i wanted to go back to the source
material and just to make it a really
fun truthful uh adaptation so we're
doing something really neat with it
something that hasn't been announced yet
but
it's going to be a little different than
you would expect awesome
yeah forward to that wow well writing
seems like it's a really short process
in your life
yeah very quick and straight to the
point well thank you for your time
and i really can't wait for people to
see this movie i think fans are going to
be satisfied
thank you for your time thanks guys
thanks for having me of course talk with
you soon have a good one
i'll make sure to ignore that question
and i'm just going to take up so much of
greg's time today
i'm going to use my power today yeah
i'll be asleep by the end of it
then that'll be the headline greg russo
falls asleep during real rejection
[Laughter]
i'm a meme dammit
you